there we go okay i think we're in good
shape dylan
wonderful you have to deal with me i'm a
little unshaven at the moment the mask
mandate has uh made me uh compliant with
uh with with the less standard of
hygiene for shaving well you know what
happens to all of us it happens to all
of us
100 so how have you been
i've been well i i appreciate you having
me on your show you it came highly
recommended that i appear with you and i
know i know we've been trying to set it
up for a while
yeah i was i was excited to i was really
excited to talk to you i didn't actually
think it was going to happen when uh
when one of the people who worked with
me actually suggested the idea so i'm
happy that it actually actually did
happen and after an exciting weekend too
at the capitol
yeah we covered when when i was
streaming saturday we picked up a little
bit of your interviews with some of the
people there
yeah it was it was some it was some very
interesting interviews
what really struck me was how readily uh
they all gave up information about
themselves not only would they state
their like full name but they would many
of them even stated yeah i was at the
capitol i tried to storm it no i haven't
the authorities have not contacted me
it's like why are you why are you saying
this in front of a camera this is a
terrible idea yeah it that was weird and
then the other thing also was
they um
you know the the organizer i think was
like advising people don't really do
interviews don't talk to people because
you you know basically it was clear that
matt brainard thought
if people are interviewed they're going
to look stupid and so he was advising
people not to and and they did i mean he
was exactly right
yeah i mean i i i the comments by the
way we just released two minutes ago
actually the uh the footage on youtube
for anybody who wants to go see that
dillenburg tv but we talked to people
who told us that like biden hated
catholics that the vaccine was evil the
mark of the beast
uh we had people tell us actually there
was one man who was flying a chinese
flag saying it's already china might as
well just like please our new overlords
right uh the there and of course there
was a person who admitted to uh
storming the capital and he said that
though he was a victim of police
brutality he was trying to like put that
angle on it and the reason why he said
he was made so much that it and this is
his wordy not mine that they maced my
balls it dripped down his whole body
they makes them so much that's uh sounds
more of a physics problem than anything
else i would i would agree there
the one thing i was going to say is and
this is listen this is a suggestion
which is worth what you paid for it
which is nothing but one of the things i
thought might be and maybe you did this
later i only watched a little bit there
were times when you were interviewing
someone and they would say something
completely crazy
and you would counterpoint them with
like an opposing fact which is obviously
great but
one of the things i stopped doing
is
one of the reasons i stopped doing that
in those situations is
we can't possibly have the opposing
facts on all of these things even if we
know people are feeding us [ __ ] so i
tend to take the approach of when i know
someone saying something completely
bonkers
just keep asking them how they learned
that how they came up with that
rather than trying to counterpoint them
because eventually you might get to a
point where your counterpoint you don't
have the facts either because what
they're saying is so cop bonkers and so
you kind of get to a standstill where i
found that it often works out better
just to keep saying really where did you
hear that how did you learn that how do
you know that that's true and then they
end up hanging themselves in a way where
maybe they wouldn't if you just keep
going point counterpoint with them it's
just an idea you know and maybe you were
doing that later too i don't know
it is true i mean i eventually ran into
a guy who was telling me how bill gates
ran the u.n and i would ask him where
where he heard that and then he of
course freaked out and that did work
better and i guess um uh what was the
old uh the old termite the whole thing i
was told it was something along the
lines of uh uh no one earns no one wins
anything from uh winning against a fool
right if you're debating somebody who's
a complete whack job you you gain
nothing if you look good they're right
job but if you actually trip up in any
way
then you just look like 10 times the
full because you lost to a complete
whack job that's another reason why i
think it's better in those situations
just to keep asking them questions about
how they learned this stuff because at
any point that you're not
as even aware of what they're talking
about it almost ends up kind of looking
like well either of them might have been
right you know what i mean
yeah i there was one moment which i
especially liked where i asked somebody
they said that everything you're saying
is oxymoronic and i said define that
word and then they just like shut down
and just just getting them just asking
them for the definitions of what they're
saying their courses that probably that
un-ironically was the best
moments and on all the interviews that i
had
um so i do agree with you on that
actually that's not surprising to me
that that happened
yeah i mean this is the third big thing
i went to the last two was the million
mag of march yep uh and that's where i
got maced by the proud boys and that was
that was a joy and wow the other one was
january 6 which uh i made the
uh the very intelligent decision to go
to the january 6th because at the time i
just thought it was going to be protest
yeah in a biden hoodie
i went there in a biden hoodie alone
which was a fool's errand i can say but
i i did not get physically assaulted so
i you know i got out better than i think
logic would say i would have gotten out
of that did authorities at all want to
talk to you just because you were there
i have never been contacted by
authorities and the thing that's
interesting about that is i got
a decent amount of pictures video
um i streamed a decent amount of it and
when i got i got up to the capitol steps
and i even i actually got i think the
only angle that's available online of
them physically attacking the reporters
oh okay as everybody knows they they
attacked the reporters took their
equipment smashed it most people have
seen the footage afterwards where
they're smashing equipment right i
actually um saw the interaction that led
up to that what happened was it was
right after most of the chaos had
happened and they were pushed out of the
capitol and so everybody's now kind of
outside the capitol kind of combating
with police as police try to gain order
and then there's the reporters there and
they have this tiny little metal gate
dividing them from from the rioters and
one of the reporters just says there's a
riot behind me at the dc capital
which is true under anyone's definition
even if you wanted to be as generous as
you wanted to the people who were
participating in that day
and one of the people there got so angry
that they used to term riot that they
came up with an american flag and
started waving in front of the camera so
they can record anything and then other
people gathered then they started
pelting them with objects before tearing
down the metal gear barrier pushing them
all out and smashing up their equipment
wow and so
basically
they rioted in response to being called
a riot it became a self-fulfilling
prophecy of sorts
exactly it became a self-fulfilling
prophecy how many hours were you were
you there that day
i was there from i would say noon to
maybe about five or six oh okay did you
bring did you bring snacks
uh i did not bring snacks uh that was
also another error i made i
maybe you know in a tricky situation i
think that if i got cornered i could
open a bag of lay's potato chips throw a
couple in the air and maybe they'd
scatter yeah yeah yeah are you bit what
are you like a barbecue guy or what
potato chip flavor
you know i salt and vinegar has always
been the way i go ooh that makes me
question this interview to be honest i
mean i i know it takes it takes a
dignifying modern man to like salt and
vinegar and i am the of the younger
variety right yeah yeah no barbecue is
barbecues the way i now i'm curious in
all seriousness were the riot did the
rioters bring food and drinks
i did not see any food and drinks there
but there were people with backpacks
they were i mean there were people with
these these like larpers and like full
military gear with everything geared up
backpacks and i'm sure if you opened it
up you wouldn't find military equipment
you'd mostly probably find like maybe
like juice boxes and snacks like some
oreos and stuff i'm sure obviously a few
of them had military equipment uh bombs
were planted at the uh at the capitol i
mean i've well at the rnc and dnc the
night before and of course there was
other other weapons found as many people
were arrested with weapons did you since
you were in the crowd did you see people
with weapons
um
i saw people using traditional objects
with weapons as weapons like like a pole
yeah like stuff like that i said i never
saw anybody like take out like a knife
or like like a baseball bat it was like
um using for example the metal gate the
barrier like using that to push against
people i never saw any uh actual like
weapons get taken out there was a lot of
people
with um i would say like military gear
like fully geared up there was a lot of
people with like like full camo or
completely in black all things covered
and they have elbow pads and everything
like they're ready for something right
sure uh like mo brooks was ready because
he had body armor for some reason
that's weird to me
yeah that's the one thing i really want
answered is why how why did mo brooks
have body armor when no one else was
supposed to when he wasn't supposed to
know of what happened or what was going
to happen it's very very strange yeah
i've not
has they has there even been an
explanation asserted for that even if
it's bs
absolutely nothing did we just know he
had
um body armor which of course obviously
implies that he thought there was a high
likelihood of violence or knew there was
going to be violence right even the best
case scenario would be
that he knew there was a high likelihood
which raises a whole other series of
obvious questions which we've not gotten
answers to
of course of course so yeah january 6
was was wild
the the thing that got me about january
6th so there was some there's a few
things that were interesting how open
people were with their calls for like
actual like revolution and overthrow
that i think
that i think is it really dug into me
with like being firsthand there like
people just calling for random
politicians to be executed right people
just calling for anybody who voted the
other way to be executed i remember
there was one interaction i had at the
capitol steps where
somebody i was i they saw my biden
hoodie and they got angry and they
started talking to me and they said i
was a traitor for just voting for biden
there was nothing else there it wasn't
like you're traitor because you're part
of biden's government or you did this
thing just merely voting the other way
made me a traitor and then later when i
was declared a traitor people what of
course followed up with
what happens to traders what's the
penalty for treatment
which what's the the obvious implication
there is you should be shot or hung or
executed in some manner sure and the
other thing that was interesting was the
weird divide amongst the protesters on
how to interact with the police because
half of them were very much like
we respect you and stuff and you're
great you're the boys in blue and the
other half was just like [ __ ] them
they're traitors they're breaking
they're oath breakers what's the term i
heard a decent amount that like that
they broke in their
and they're therefore they're against
the people and that i guess was their
justification for them attacking a group
they are usually very supportive of but
what a wild day
like conflict with each other yeah it
was
um i had no clue i was in for that type
of a day and i wouldn't have gone alone
or in a biden hoodie if i knew that was
against that's why i didn't go to this
weekend at a bite and hoodie because
right no i think that was smart now you
were wearing a mask in a lot of the
interviews i saw
did anybody mention anything about that
because most of the people there were
not wearing masks yeah most of the
people there were not where i would say
maybe like one in four to maybe one at
three if i'm being very generous with
wearing masks and most of those people
were counter protesters counter
protesters a lot of them just went in
and out i think protests at free which
actually surprised me the cops were very
very ready they had the basically
surrounded i looked up to the capitol
steps and there were cops all over it
they were not taking any chances which i
would assume after losing so many of
their colleagues
there's a reason why they're not taking
any chances right um but when it comes
to masks i was they never brought up my
mask they did bring up are you do you
have the mark of the beast right have
you been vaccinated and i would always
say yes and then they'd like go on a
diatribe for five minutes about how i've
accepted satan or or bill gates's spawn
or i'm a u.n dog something along those
lines did anybody uh tell you to step
away because you were shedding vaccine
on them
once actually that did happen somebody
did uh tell me like
um like hey i don't need that i don't
need the mask i you need to keep that
mask to keep that vaccine away from me
right that's something actually was cut
out of the final footage we uploaded to
youtube but you can still find that in
the vault on my twitch channel if
somebody wanted to see that there was
this there was this fellow that was very
interesting he looked like somebody just
came straight out of the coal mines in a
pickup truck right i don't know how else
to describe the man no mask no nothing
he had his whole depopulation sign he
was implying that the vaccines were
depopulation and and he was telling me
how bill gates owns the un and i said
how
and then
that was where that interaction
basically ended where he's like well how
i mean like he just does and like well
okay it was what about the vaccine
that's that's
bill gates too how and then of course it
would trip him up again so there was no
deeper explanation
there was no deeper explanation what he
would tell me is that wow you're a
reporter and you haven't done the
research as if he he asserts that bill
gates owns right right right supposed to
have a record of bill gates finances on
hand while i'm at a protest to do with
nothing associated with bill gates
so are you i mean the the i'm guessing
you're you weren't you're not dissuaded
from doing more of these in-person
things because it was basically fine
over the weekend
oh yeah i mean the the first two i went
to were obviously the most violent the
millionaire magamarch um i actually had
to try to get medical help for somebody
who was stabbed oh my god we were
charged uh which was
that was an experience wow
and the dc protests or january 6
instruction whatever the hell you want
to call it that obviously um while i
never had physical violence done against
me that night which i still think is a
miracle
i saw enough of it and i saw enough type
of rhetoric thrown my way to
elite teach me a few lessons on how to
approach protests going forward like you
never go alone right a big tip i'd
always give everybody because what would
happen a lot of times with the proud
boys of the millenne magamarge is they
would find people walking home alone and
if they wearing too much black you're
just going to get jumped right on the
belief that they're antifa or what yes
oh i think that they're anti-fun
if you're wearing too much black then
you look like antifa you're going to get
jumped right and you don't know how much
help you're going to get from the cops
sometimes it's a lot sometimes it's none
it really depends on their resources it
depends on where they are and a lot of
times you'll just like watch the cops
will be there and nothing will happen
maybe it's because they don't feel they
have the means to do it or i have no
clue i'm not an expert in police tactics
right always go with like buddies
um would be like the number one tip i've
learned because the first two times i
didn't go with buddies and that was
and i'm very lucky that nothing happened
to me yeah that seems at minimum like
the minimum you want to do go go in a
group
um so what did you want to talk about
today i know i mean you're you know
you're uh is it is it producer do you
have a production team is that who was
contacting me uh danabo is my assistant
he was the one who thought uh me talking
to you was a good idea yeah and so he
was just like let me just message him i
was like sure whatever i didn't think i
didn't think anything was obviously
something dead yeah yeah yeah he didn't
say too much about what you what did you
want to talk about i mean i'm glad to
talk about whatever if i just don't know
i'll say i don't know
okay i mean i was i was just willing to
talk about i think the the biggest
things i wanted to talk about well first
was those two events uh generally
because i know that like there's not a
lot of first-hand accounts and we just
had one over the weekend
but another thing i wanted to talk to
you at length about specifically wait
one second i had a list no come back to
my list i have terrible memory uh
oh actually was the afghanistan
withdrawal oh okay she's gotten a lot of
a lot of notice so first i just want to
ask you what is your general
i
idea around number one did you support
the withdrawal and number two how do you
think biden handled it i i support and
supported the withdrawal um i uh yeah i
i think you know we were there
too long
to put it lightly um i think that the
handling could have been better
but i also think that trump would have
screwed up the withdrawal um i think it
became clear you know when trump was
interviewed on newsmax when he was
actually asked well what would you have
done differently there wasn't really
anything that he presented that he would
have done differently
um and i uh you know i am really
disgusted with with this
corporate media
um concern i almost call it concern
trolling where they've scrutinized the
withdrawal after 20 years more than they
ever scrutinized being there
and um even like the drone strike
which you know this commander the
centcom commander recently said
um hey you know what we didn't get isis
k we got 10 civilians including maybe
like seven kids i think it was and we're
sorry
even the media seizing on that it's like
we were talking about that all the time
under obama but it just wasn't really
interesting to corporate media in the
same way so even that feels like another
way to kind of say
we told you the withdrawal was a bad
idea look at this drone strike that went
wrong even though there's
hundreds thousands of instances
of uh
of similar of similar drone strikes that
did not garner that much attention so
yeah i'm i'm glad that we are out
to the extent that we're really out
right and there's a question as to
whether you know that the contractors go
back in or are we fully out um i think
that at a certain point
even though you break it you buy it
applies to some degree
at a certain point when it becomes clear
that just staying another year or two or
three or four
isn't actually going to fix anything
um you have to say
we are now getting out
what i found interesting about what
you're saying here is
not only did they give more attention to
withdrawal but there was many norms that
were broken under trump when it came to
afghanistan and just general foreign
policy like
behavior that did not get nearly as much
coverage for example if we're so
concerned about drone strikes which
obviously the drone strike is horrific
the fact that civilians died i've
covered it on my channel it deserves to
be covered but where was this attention
to detail when
trump escalated drone strike use by
massive numbers in afghanistan yeah not
only did he do that but he followed it
up by restricting access to information
about said drone strikes so he first he
escalates drone strikes drops the mother
of all bombs on afghanistan on
afghanistan the moab and then restricts
access
to the data about what he's now doing in
afghanistan and across the middle east
right yeah i think that that's part of
why
the there's the political and there's
the media coverage
the media coverage seems so cynical so
cynical
it i i 100 believe it which is
frustrating for me as somebody who who
specializes in specifically foreign
policy because what i'm what i'm
watching happen in afghanistan right now
is absolutely horrific right women have
now basically been told they're not
going to be able to get secondary
education education it's like middle
school and high school but that what we
would think of that in afghanistan
america is not going to be available to
women and girls boys have gone back to
school women have not that's the same
thing they did with work in the 90s that
they just said hey don't go to work
right now and it wasn't until america
invaded that that policy of course was
reversed
uh we have seen the tick tock comedians
get executed we have seen all these
horrific things happen and i and i'm
covering them and it's important to
cover these things but what what sucks
is i feel like
number one these things are now getting
more attention because we're not there
and it's easy to basically like like say
well see this is all the fault of the
withdrawal and number two
it's aggravating because i feel like i'm
sitting there and i'm talking about all
these human rights abuses and everybody
and these people walk into the room and
they're like oh yeah i agree with you
and then i'll move on to say saudi
arabia or i'll move on to say um well
let's talk about women's rights in the
united states let's talk about texas and
then the room just everybody exits like
never mind okay i'm gone yeah we don't
want to hold those standards universally
the other thing this reminds me of
that's also just kind of an absurdity of
the way that these things are talked
about is
um i don't know any i i don't want to
like gatekeep with the term real
progressive or real leftist but i think
the point i'm trying to make is
i don't know
any serious critics of our involvement
in afghanistan
who think the taliban is is great
or
trustworthy or whatever and there's been
this um sort of like black white
reaction where if you say you like the
withdrawal in that you think it's the
right thing
all of a sudden there's oh you want to
be negotiating with the taliban and
you're the these are the people and then
they pull out the pictures like no the
taliban's horrible and the taliban was
horrible when trump was negotiating with
them and the taliban's been horrible for
a long time but that's a different
question then
what are we staying for what will be
achieved by staying and is it is it the
right decision they're really they're
related questions but they're they're
separate issues
yeah i i find it hard to believe
that also the standard is held
universally because there's been many
times in american history that these
same individuals who are crying foul
right now have negotiated with powers as
bad or or pretty bad inc in comparison
with the taliban or just generally for
example
stalin was an absolute monster he was
one of the worst human beings to ever
exist on the planet but we negotiated
with him in world war ii because we saw
a bigger enemy right sure we have
negotiated with saudi arabia which has a
terrible human rights record we've
negotiated with right-wing death strat
uh death squads in latin america for our
own benefit even though we 100 shouldn't
have even been there in the first place
right and so it's weird for me to see
this this crying foul on the idea of of
any compromise whatsoever after they've
failed on a certain strategy for 20
years now let's say that
it was year one or two maybe you could
have an argument like okay it's the
first two years against the fight
against the taliban maybe you're right
maybe we should just but it's been 20
years 20 years of failed strategy now
you can maybe unless you want to tell me
okay let's go another 20 years then you
have to at least give credence to the
idea of looking at other strategies and
how to deal yeah yeah yeah well that's
the question right which is for those
that are now saying well we should have
stayed
the question is
how long would be reasonable because if
20 years didn't
accomplish whatever
one year more is unlikely to do it so
then you're already talking about well
by saying stay are you saying stay five
more years are you saying another 20.
and you know there were a couple i don't
remember who there they were but there
were a couple of neocon neocons i saw in
right-wing media who were actually
honest and they were like yeah we should
just have a permanent presence there and
it's like while i disagree
well i disagree completely at least
they're just being upfront and they're
like i think leaving's bad because we
should just stay forever that's it and
it's like okay all right i can deal with
you if you're honest in that sense
that's only the first part of the puzzle
too because then the question isn't just
how long are we staying but also what
are we going to change in strategy right
because
i would not dedicate a soldier to stay
another day in a country if our
strategy's failing and we don't have
another strategy to fix it because at
that point what you're doing is you're
just clogging holes in a sinking ship
and you're just going with the same old
strategy that hasn't worked for the last
20 years we have no reason to believe
that it's going to work in the next 20.
i would also say on the other hand and i
do want to bring attention to this that
it also has been difficult as somebody
who
covers these human rights abuses that's
going on in afghanistan and covered them
while the withdrawal was happening and
talking about what the reality was going
to be with the taliban ruling
afghanistan to any time i'd bring that
up it felt like somebody would say
i would bring up the taliban or awful
evil and bad and we need to talk about
what the reality is going to be for
women in afghanistan and someone say
what sounds like just pro-war machine
propaganda where i think that left
wingers generally need to acknowledge
the consequences of foreign policy
decisions that we cannot pretend
that if when we exit a country or when
we leave this environment that
everything is going to be peaches and
cream and everything is going to be
wonderful we need to acknowledge the
pain that's going to be caused to women
and minority groups like the hazard
population of afghanistan
and talk about what we should do moving
forward to best help them my strategy is
to take in as many refugees as
physically possible and then see where
we can go from there right
uh but it felt like also anytime i bring
up any of that there would also be a
weird a weird um virtue signally
backlash in the other direction i hate
to play to both sides on that but it
felt weird no there was it was going on
now what do you imagine that because
remember trump trump announced the same
plan to leave afghanistan trump
announced it imagine trump had done it
and the same chaos had taken place
what would the trump pr machine have
done would they simply have said hey you
got to blame george w bush he's the guy
who got us in and just left it at that
and not explained anything else and just
made it that cut and dry
i think the first thing i do want to say
about trump that's interesting about
afghanistan is he started his
administration
with a troop increase in afghanistan
increasing drone strikes restricting
data to that information and helping the
moab and then by the end of his
administration which he was saying
on the campaign trail bomb the families
with terrorists he's like well let me
negotiate with some of them yeah
yeah just to complete 180 and it shows
that and i mean this that a lot of
people like to like to say that trump's
like just like like an isolationist or
he has this foreign policy he doesn't
have any fundamental foreign policy
beliefs right he he just sticks his
finger in the air and goes that way he
was for the war in iraq he was four
intervening in libya he was he was four
going into afghanistan he was for all
these conflicts and now that is
politically beneficial he's going the
other way he just sticks his finger in
the air so i just i just want to like
say that he has the fundamental form of
course
so i i honestly think that he probably
would have stayed maybe with the may
deadline that he set i have no reason to
believe and he hasn't indicated that he
would have switched that deadline
and i think that
he would have handled the situation
either as bad or worse
because i don't know if he could have
been able to have the logistical skills
or be able to point the right people in
the right direction to have one of the
largest airlifts in human history
because i will say the biden
administration most certainly dropped
the ball in a few things i'm sure the
leaving of biometric data um his oh my
god the interview after the um the
person fell off the plane to their death
and he's like oh that's four or five
days i mean that's just terribly callous
right
absolutely
i think maybe a higher level of
callousness might have been shown by a
different individual
and i don't know if he would have been
able to do that airlift or pick or been
able to re-pick up the ball right right
so that's that's the way i like to
classify uh biden's withdrawal is he's
dropped the ball then he picked it up
and did what he could do in the fastest
way possible
a trump withdrawal would have been
months earlier in may
he would not have had the logistical
skill or the management skills to get
this done
and he would have been 10 times more
callous and all those allies that were
talking about we needed to support and
bring out needed to be included in the
airlift they would have been considered
less because he plays to a base of
people who don't like to take in
refugees he said on the campaign trail i
want a total and complete shutdown of
muslims entering in the united states
yeah now it might surprise people to
hear this but uh afghanistan actually
has a lot of those
uh yeah and within the borders of
afghanistan and so and you see the
right-wing fear-monger machine right now
biden's bringing in a horde of refugees
i russia today actually edited
ak-47s and rpgs onto the backs i saw
that with their children going on and
wasn't there explanation that it was
satire but like there was nothing that
would indicate that it was satire it was
one of the strangest explanations it was
just not it just looked like a story
headline it was weird um russia today
has a long history of pushing like just
their main goal is to push divisive
divisive messaging to the highest extent
for divisiveness sake and for clicks
another example of this is i remember
when hillary clinton uh they they had
this story that i think has been removed
from the youtube since then if this
person talking about how basically the
jews are controlling a large part of
hillary clinton's campaign and then hey
look there's a triangle in one of the
symbols of their company and it was just
posted yeah oh yeah it was posted on the
youtube eventually was taken down but
they have a long history of pushing and
uh blatantly uh bigoted messaging yeah
so let's see i i i generally speaking
agree with you about how trump would
have handled the withdrawal i think the
reaction uh would would have been
callous is probably an understatement
but i i certainly agree with you about
that i do think that you know trump was
able to
[Music]
come up with these
it's not just they weren't just
incoherent but they were almost like
satirical
public positions when he would screw
stuff up
um and i'm kind of i'm almost i have
like a morbid curiosity what kind of
insane thing with jared kushner have
dreamed up to explain
the exact same level of chaos or even
more if trump
did actually oversee the withdrawal from
from afghanistan it's cert i don't
actually know what it would be
but you know particularly on kovid and
on hurricanes like on everything he was
just able to do stuff who could imagine
i am scared that he would have done the
withdrawal than reversed his decision oh
interesting why is because if we see
syria now that was a withdrawal that was
horribly botched and didn't even need to
happen because when you look at the
withdrawal he pulled the troops out of
northeastern syria off the border after
making the kurds the ypj and the ypg
disarm themselves on the border with the
deal with turkey
then he moves them back they get
slaughtered politicians get dragged out
of cars and shot i don't i don't need to
describe the brutal but it was terrible
he redeploys them in iraq says they're
coming home and then just redeploys them
back into syria right just completely
reverses the decision the only
difference was now they were in a worse
strategic position and now thousands
more people were dead that was the only
difference and so my fear is and that
was due to the backlash of people
walking into his office and pointing at
charts and saying but there's oil in
syria trump that was i think that was
mitch mcconnell who did that so that my
fear is that he would have been going
through with this withdrawal made the
deal with the taliban gone with this
made deadline been as catastrophical
more catastrophic than midway through
after chaos was happening since he has
no fundamental foreign policy beliefs
and joe biden for years has talked about
in private how he wanted to get out of
afghanistan he there's there's a lot of
these things coming out in 20 from um i
think it was 2011 where he had a
conversation with a staffer with someone
who was trying to convince him like
maybe we should stay for the feminism
he's like not a dude that's nonsense
that's nonsensical right
i'm curious though if it if the wind
pushed him in that direction he could he
could have reversed his position on
afghanistan like that yeah yeah i don't
i don't disagree um i think though that
there is
you know trump will sometimes off-ramp
things that he promises
but he'll never really just say i
changed my mind because because the
situation changed you know he'll say
well someone blocked me from doing it or
it's rhinos or it's democrats or
whatever so while i agree with you that
on policy he could have ended up saying
we're not doing it or we're going back
in but he never would have said because
it got chaotic and i didn't predict that
he would always have figured out some
way to either blame other republicans
who got in the way or democrats or
whoever because that's always that's
it's just there's no instances where he
said i miscalculated you would have put
it probably on the afghans that the the
a a just collapsed so fast because the
afghan people are just so cowardly and
so terrible i think hey that's a a
foreign enemy he can pin it on right
that's the type of thing as a type of
dialogue i can see i'm doing because you
can see that dialogue going on right now
because there's so many reports of a a
soldiers being tremendously brave but if
you don't have supplies you don't have
ammunition and you are also starving
there's many reports of them just not
getting fed even and not paid on top of
that right
and you're facing the taliban like yeah
no [ __ ] many of them weren't able to
hold out right
but he could just pin it on the cowardly
uh foreigners not being able to hold up
defense even though we've saved them for
20 years i could see him running running
along with that i mean that's what
they're doing right now i mean they're
saying why do all these afghans need to
come to america why aren't they at home
fighting the taliban fighting for their
own country if they love these values so
much
i'm curious because you you know you
mentioned the rt edited uh image you
know with the the afghans
and the weapons the rocket launcher i
think it was or whatever the case it was
there's a there's a contingent i mean rt
is controversial on the left not for me
like i i'm i'm an anti-authoritarian
period so any kind of authoritarian
leaders and their associated state media
entities i'm very skeptical about
garbage i don't uh i don't use rt as a
source i don't use telesur as a source i
don't use al jazeera you know we it
doesn't doesn't matter we could go on
and do the full list but
what do you think it is about
that fundamentally underlies this
disagreement on the left about a network
like rt
i i think that the problem is that
press tv russia today or al jazeera or
any of these um and al jazeera
unironically i will watch some of their
documentaries or i for example i love
mehdi hassan i think maddie hassan is an
amazing journalist and he was with al
jazeera for years he was yeah he would
do this amazing head-to-head series
which is phenomenal that was great
everybody go check it out and i would
see that and that reporting and his work
was phenomenal on the network right
and so
when you see good sources or good people
within a larger network doing good stuff
that's gonna rub you in in a good way
it's gonna make you think you know maybe
this is something worthwhile to listen
to and then you you and then you
condense that with the fact that russia
today and press tv a lot of times have
anti-like american imperialist messaging
why because russia serves it russia
today serves a different imperial
overlord right so it's not out of
anti-imperialist interests is out of
anti-americanism it's the same thing
with gray's own it's not out of actual
anti-imperial interests it's out of
just anti-americanism
i'm not familiar with that one
uh you never you're not familiar with
grayzone no
you've never interacted with grayzone
before ever who does that latte
uh jimmy dore uses them as a source all
the time i've i've never watched jimmy
dore i've i've i've heard the name aaron
mate but
oh max i've met a couple matt max i've
met a couple of times
yeah
well well
these different types of sources i think
they a lot of times can unironically hit
the nail on the head where they'll if
something bad happens america does
something bad they'll criticize it
they'll point it out and they're correct
but then the problem is the reason
they're pointing it out is different
than the reason that somebody else is
pointed out their their interests and
their motives are different and then
with that they'll splice it in with man
isn't it terrible that they're doing all
this and let me tell you how great the
russian government was in supporting
assad and then those lace in their own
personal injuries yeah that's why we
need to be concerned because you're not
going to see russia today calling out
bashar al-assad's use of barrel bombs
you're not going to see press tv talking
about the treatment of women in iran
you're not going to see that reporting
done because it doesn't interest those
who fund the programs
yeah you know the thing um that i've
talked about i mean this is starting to
sort of get into
really the debate even among the left
about quote russia gate as some people
like to call it
where
you know as i've said before
you have this spectrum where on one side
you might have like putin and trump in a
room planning something right which i
mean maybe someone was saying that i was
never saying that you go back to april
2017 and i'm saying guys if that's what
you're waiting for you're going to be
sorely disappointed on the other side is
just kind of like the systemic critique
that you're putting together which is
hey you know what particularly when you
think geopolitically about china russia
and the united states as like the three
superpowers um there is a
to some degree a zero-sum nature of that
and the authoritarian uh um uh regime of
vladimir putin comparatively looks
better
if democracy looks like it's in peril in
the united states if things look really
chaotic in the united states so it's
like of course they would prefer the
doofus trump to hillary that's very
different than putin and trump got
together and planned something if that
if that if i'm being clear
yeah
the thing that gets me
is every time i hear somebody well you
probably believe in russiagate which is
something you'll commonly see in like
twitter section one yeah yeah yeah is
it's not really an issue of debate
anymore what what what happens there's
certain details that are foggy right yep
but when it comes to the internet
research agency when it comes to the
multiple reports put out by our
intelligence agency clarifying very
clearly that they did spread
disinformation on the internet to
benefit one political candidate because
they thought the other would act against
their interests that is absolutely clear
now you can downplay that if you want
but it is true that they attempted to
interfere in both the 2016 elections and
to a lesser extent the 2020 election
that is just a fact now you can say oh
so you're just saying they just posted a
lot of memes
they tried to spread this information
online to try to tip the scale on one
way i'm i'm pretty sure in other any
other circumstance if it didn't if it
didn't benefit your political uh if it
if it went the other way let's say that
it was the chinese government
spread this information online in the
united states to help joe biden sure and
then a report came out showing that
right and it was saying hunter biden
best intellectual of this century
big-brained uh amazing man big chad
money muscle
and we saw those types of stuffs being
spread on the internet by the chinese
government and their internet research
agency do you really think we would get
the same down plane or would it be
chinese propaganda destroys american
election it would be a totally it would
be a hundred percent the same type of
coverage that we got on the rachel
maddow show
of this and if this issue yeah and then
there's one other thing as well which is
sometimes there will be sort of like
rebuttals that aren't really substantive
rebuttals which like i'll give you a
couple of examples one would be
um
yeah but russia's doing that in a lot of
countries
i would agree with you that's not
actually a rebuttal i've done an inter
i've done interviews about that and and
that actually would be sort of like an
aggravator that would make us think well
then why wouldn't they try it in the
united states and then the other one
that will sometimes be put together is
well but the u.s has a history of doing
the same thing it's like of course look
at latin america as you mentioned before
i we can be against that too that
doesn't change the reality of what took
place they're not really rebuttals
they aren't rebuttals and i the thing
the thing against me about the later
example is so what you're saying is that
you're acknowledging that when america
did that it was bad right right so then
you would acknowledge that this is bad
as well then obviously unless what you
mean is we deserve it and therefore
they're right like why would how is that
even relevant otherwise well than that
it just becomes like like somebody like
taking a belt and like hurting
themselves at that point that's like
almost advocating for the like the type
of weird self-harm of the united states
so yeah i i feel that people just want
to downplay what happened or they want
to just kind of petty fog the issue but
ultimately the fact of the matter is
that the russian government attempted
through the internet research agency to
affect the outcomes of both the 2016 and
to a lesser extent of 2020 elections
through spreading disinformation on the
internet that is an undeniable fact and
i think anytime somebody brings up
russiagate or mocks it just put it in
that framing and just don't move from
the point they can try to say oh they
posted a few memes and i'm and then you
can say actually we can just look at the
report and see exactly what they did
because the dis you can say it's a few
memes it wasn't a few memes their
disinformation were seen by millions
upon millions upon millions of people
and when you're talking about election
where one candidate hillary clinton won
the popular vote and the other didn't
win the popular vote and some of the
races in some of these states were a lot
closer than i think some people in both
camps would have liked
they can have an actual impact yeah i
mean i think um that's not even a talk
about the actual efforts of the russian
government to hack into that's a totally
separate issue that's separate i think
either way if you come up against the
determined denier they'll kind of use
the same lines which is well
your sourcing on that is from
untrustworthy
uh organizations or too much of the data
is still classified so we don't really
know i mean like you know they'll
they'll you can still get stonewalled on
that stuff yeah i i think what it is is
that it's an inconvenient fact
that people want to pretend
that for what i don't know why it could
be any number of reasons
it could be either your trump supporter
and maybe it makes you feel that the
election would feel less legitimate if
trump won
uh with the backing of a foreign
government i mean that's the type of
thing that they would like to accuse the
democrats of dewey not the republicans i
mean that's exactly what happened in
2020 hunter biden china is in china's
pocket that's exactly what happened four
years after 2016.
um and maybe there's some people who
don't want don't like the idea that the
russian government tried to interfere or
uh an american maybe part of it is
making american exceptionalists like nah
there's no way the foreigners could
could have an impact on american
elections
maybe some people have an interest in
just believing that russia had no
involvement because russia said they
didn't have involved well there's one
other there's one other uh section which
is i i don't know if they still would
would cop to this but early
there were bernie people
who
wanted to believe that
so the logic would be bernie was the
better candidate than hillary
bernie would have beaten hillary so we
need to believe that trump really beat
hillary fair and square
if russia did try or succeed at helping
trump
then maybe hillary would have won which
undercuts our view that bernie was the
better candidate and actually would have
won so i think that's another contingent
i i think that could possibly be i
haven't seen as much of that i think
i've seen it maybe on a few occasions
yeah
but i
there is and
there's a thing that really angers me
about this is
there are there are people who try to
say and point to the fact that hillary
clinton acknowledges that this happened
right and she talks about this to point
to the fact see hillary clinton didn't
accept the results of the 2016 election
why does donald trump need to accept the
results of the 2020 election even though
hillary of course
called uh mr trump
literally the day after yeah and said
hey
you're president i give up i'm tapping
out right and all the legal challenges
that they try to bring up she dropped
them all of them did she didn't pursue
any of those not to mention trump still
doesn't accept the results of the 2016
election
the the thing that gets me about trump
is he has been telling people he was
going to do this for the last five years
right he said during on the republican
campaign trail when he lost any a
primary he would say was due to fraud or
was stolen or was rigged or there was
some factor like
evil ben carson or ted cruz or whatever
right that's also and this is a fun fact
that's also where donald trump laid the
foundations for the growth in the
anti-vaxxer movement when he said that
vaccines cause autism on the same stage
as a medical expert and ben carson did
not sufficiently call him out and i
think that laid the foundation for a lot
of what we're seeing no doubt then after
being elected
um and then of course on the on the
debate stage he said he didn't answer if
he would accept the results of the
election then come 2019
to the lead-up of the next election he
said if he loses it's rigged he he has
been very open that if he ever loses
just outright loses he's not going to
accept the results
and so i don't understand how people can
see him priming this up then he pulls
the trigger
on this
and people are like
wow i'm so shocked i can't believe the
democrats stole it and they're
legitimately believing this he's been
setting this lie up for five years yeah
and they're applying it i mean look you
know if you watched what happened with
larry elder last week they're they're
now just using it in other elections
there's a video of a woman confronting
mitt romney in uh washington at reagan
airport where she goes up to him and
says you didn't really win your utah
senate race that was that was also fraud
it's just going to be it's the new thing
you know and here's the concern i have
and i wonder if you share this concern
and maybe not maybe the concern is
overblown
that it'll become like a reverse boy who
cried wolf
which is at some point
republicans really might find a way to
fraudulently steal an election and
democrats might actually call it out and
then republicans will say guys we've
been calling this out for so long and
you always said we were lying we can't
listen to you now did you see the six
points that were released uh about how
uh how about how mike pence was supposed
to steal the election so i i bookmarked
some articles and i'm gonna cover it
tomorrow but my understanding is the
gist of it was the alternate slate of
electors was like a big part of the plan
yeah it seemed that basically he was
gonna have mike pence fly down to
arizona say it's all fraud so all of
these don't count trump is president and
then and then in it he even says now the
democrats the boohoo democrats might not
accept that and so then we go to the
house it's a fraud which is still
technically republican-controlled at the
time it was
and then boom baby we got this 11.
don't don't even sweat it they're going
to sue us we'll just fight them in court
right right absolutely and um
basically what they were
basically just saying with this if if
this was completely let's say this was
all legally true this would imply
that all you needed to do to steal a
presidential election is just have the
house of representatives right exactly
yeah and you know a willing participant
i guess and a vice president in order to
publicize that this is what's going on
and this this is what's being done which
you know now there's people saying like
thank goodness it was pence and not matt
gates as the vp or something like that i
i don't know i mean i'm still thinking
about how much of a difference that
really would have made in the end i
don't know if the thing is i feel that
there is no legal basis for what they
were going to do no so therefore even if
you put the biggest trump sycophant in
there unless it's somebody who actually
believes trump's nonsense which i don't
know if matt gates uh uh or as i call
him pedogates really believes uh the
nonsense or if he's just a political
opportunity if he's a political
opportunist then he's not gonna be able
to do anything and he'll just probably
just stand there or maybe he said i
tried to and the evil democrats stopped
me or something like that yeah no
question
i doubt a real attempt would would
legitimately be made i agree i tend to
agree
um
dil so i don't i don't know if you if
word got you i have like about an hour
which started you know like 50 minutes
ago so
were there other things you wanted to
talk to me about i know your your
audience is mentioning a lot of
different things and i'm glad to talk
about anything i don't want to feel like
we short change anything well it's uh i
i didn't know it was gonna i i was told
it was gonna be a conversation on an
interview so if you have any questions
for me that's fine either but i can go
to chat and uh for the last question uh
oh sure uh we can do chat participation
chat what do you want me to ask david oh
my god this is exciting let me ask you a
question david me that's a very
important question oh sure yeah uh
what's your favorite ice cream
oof uh you know lately i'm into
greyton's black cherry chocolate chip
it's pretty strong
you really like to fill the liberal
elitist
is that an elite flavor
it feels like it just i listened to that
and it just felt like like i heard like
a clinging of a silver spoon hit the
floor so it fell out of your mouth when
you said that it's 4.99 for a pint i
mean is that pricey i don't know i don't
know it was just it was just the name
right it just sounded very fancy oh my
god i mean i'm generally speaking a
pistachio guy like whenever i i am
trying a new ice cream place
usually i kind of judge them by
pistachio
so this is this is the thing i'll just
ask you and you can ramble about it i
won't i won't ask you any more about it
but this is something that people have
people uh
have been telling me to ask you about
this before
um because it was something a while ago
and i covered this
a lot of people uh are were very upset
about your coverage on bolivia
were they i didn't know that
yeah there was maybe one or two people
who were upset about that so so i had a
question what do you think about the the
outrage do you think they had any fair
critique do you think it was just an
outrage mob what do you think about that
so on a bunch of these issues like um
venezuela
bolivia
um
what other examples are even argentina
i'm from argentina i don't know if you
knew that but just as a sort of
mentioned you know to mention i'm i was
born in argentina um and and came to the
u.s
i am
very uh
critical
of what i consider faux populist faux
left populists
i've been around the block too long on
latin american politics
to
be kind of entranced by
these figures that many american
leftists sort of fall in love with as
the poverty solvers and the democracy
bringers and this type of thing
and unfortunately you know how before i
was saying
on afghanistan
there it's almost like you can't both be
for the withdrawal but not a taliban
lover like people say well if you're for
the withdrawal you must love the taliban
or otherwise you would say we have to
stay in
similarly
there's a lot of the same thing
happening with me on latin america where
because i pointed out
some of the limitations of um uh
you know the chavez maduro regime and
its authoritarian nature people started
accusing me of supporting american
cia selection of guido and i made it
very clear i don't want the us involved
i'm from latin america and i understand
the long disastrous history of american
involvement and
all i'm saying is i'm an
anti-authoritarian
and chavez maduro they control the media
they control the courts so i i have to
be against that as an anti-authoritarian
progressive but i don't want the u.s
involved and i'm not in favor of guido
similar in bolivia
i made very clear
even in the first segment which was the
source of a lot of the criticism hey
guys
the w what was the woman's name uh jean
uh anya i don't even remember you know
the though
yeah
i said this seems to be a right-wing nut
and it's quite plausible that
yeah that she's gonna take over and but
that doesn't mean and i don't want the
u.s involved but that doesn't mean that
i have to love everything that's been
going on in bolivia so basically you
know the
my basic view of this now would be
um
i know that people whenever i appear on
any show love to talk about this like
it's number one you know the the
foremost thing on my mind i don't think
i've even mentioned it for two years at
this point it doesn't really bother me
it's fine for people to
have to either say i'm either good or
bad on that issue uh i think it's overly
simplistic
but it's not surprising
given that kind of black white knee-jerk
tendency that that i see among many on
left and right
okay
uh
so i just one clarifying question what
do you think of evil morales
i think that he is a
slightly
less how do i want to say it
i think he is
more genuine
in his
package of id of ideas
than someone like chavez or maduro
so i don't see him as the same type of
authoritarian as as like chavez maduro
but
i think that
he fell
quite short of what i would see as a
kind of
ideal of social democracy rather than
this kind of populist rhetoric that in
latin america often falls so woefully
short i think that's the way i would
kind of summarize it okay one last
question
is a hot dog a sandwich
um is a hot dog a sandwich i don't know
i mean i ask people that question very
often and i don't really know the answer
i i would say it is not
you don't think it would be in the
category of like sub sandwich then
i think it would be and i mean it's sort
of like a corn dog and a corn dog isn't
really a sandwich
you're just wrapping meat in carbs
well now i believe you are a fascist
i don't know listen i stopped eating
pork a long time ago so i'm kind of out
of that of the of the hot dog game
although i will occasionally have an
all-beef kosher dog you know
okay so uh that's all the questions i i
i have or um don't want to take any more
of your time i just do want to say one
thing though is i'm actually i'm
actually 20 um and i've been uh involved
in like local electoral politics and
like all this stuff since i was like 16
17. and i got to say that when i was
like getting into politics you were one
of the shows that helped me actually get
into politics no way and i yeah and so i
just wanted to um thank you for that man
i appreciate that it's great to have
more p you're almost as old as the david
pakman show
well then it would make sense right i
guess you were four when the show
started i was six and you were four when
the show started so that that all adds
up before i was uh playing like uh i
don't know what i was playing the
nintendo wii maybe i don't know when was
the wii release though that was 2006. i
could my parents didn't allow me to have
video games so i don't know
really yeah why was that
they just thought it was bad i don't
know
i mean i had video games i had computer
games i want to make it clear i had
computer games all along but no consoles
i think they didn't like the idea of not
only the computer but also the tv being
taken over by video games i think that
was really it
was really have you played video games
since then have you tried them of course
of course of course
awesome you like any video games
i'm i'm sort of just like i play the
grand theft auto games that was that's
like a series i've been into since i was
a lot younger
um you know like uh when former producer
lewis told me to get portal i i bought
portal and played portal but i i don't
really know much about the whole culture
you know if someone has me play
something i'll play it but i don't
really know you know people talk about
valorant i don't know i have no clue
what that is i couldn't tell you what
that is don't don't don't just don't do
it don't get sucked into that legal
legends don't touch either of those okay
is valorent a first person shooter it is
a first person shooter oh it is oh okay
shooter it's a team based shooter gotcha
okay and it's it's only is it single
player or it's only played multiplayer
oh it's only made played multiplayer
okay got it got it i'm more of a single
player i like stories like i like i like
a video game that's like a movie almost
i love red dead redemption 2 for example
you know there was a game that when we
got our first computer
which was like a hundred megahertz
pentium which at the time you had the
hundred megahertz and the 75 and it was
like we're going with a hundred it's
going to be so blazing fast a game
called pitfall came with the computer
and i remember being into that game a
long time ago
well david i'm i'm happy uh oh i'm
getting a little blurry now so i guess
that's a single from my computer that i
need to skedaddle thank you so much for
having me on um can i just shout out my
stuff quick please yeah okay uh i might
be extremely blurry now but uh you know
what you can't find me blurry on my
youtube channel dylan burns tv we're
pushing it really hard right now we're
trying to get it to 50k we just released
a video of all my footage uh all the
interesting footage from my time at the
capitol uh please go check it out at
dylan burns tv that's dylan uh that's
dylan burns tv and thanks david i really
appreciate you having me on yeah my
pleasure and uh you know if anybody in
your audience wants to find me we're
trying to get to a hundred thousand on
twitch so just please follow me on
twitch and uh as far as i know that's
still legal as tucker carlson likes to
say
um for now for now yeah
you're not lauren southern you haven't
been banned yet i have not yet been
banned yeah exactly that you've been
banned
awesome see you later man all right
thanks keep up the great work you too
man okay see ya
all right there is dylan burns um
[Music]
wow
wow
uh
we'll post that to the youtube channel i
think that was a great uh a great
conversation all right guys
thank you for joining me trump rally
saturday
i will see you then